The Strangest Thing Ever Found On the Set
of a TV Show
In 1977, The Six Million Dollar Man was a
hit TV series starring Lee Majors.
That year, the show was filming an episode,
Carnival of Spies, at Nu-Pike, a museum-park
in Long Beach, California.
During filming, one of the crew was instructed
to move a mannequin.
The mannequin was painted fluorescent orange;
it was dressed in a cowboy outfit and was
hanging from a rope.
When the crew member tried to lift it, one
of the mannequin’s arms broke off.
Horrified, the cast and crew soon discovered
that this “mannequin” was actually a human
body!
The cowboy dummy was later discovered to be
a man named Elmer McCurdy who lived from 1880-1911.
Incredibly, the corpse’s identity was revealed
by two items found in McCurdy’s mouth: a
1924 penny and a ticket to the Museum of Crime
in Los Angeles.
From these two items, the story of the corpse
was reconstructed.
Elmer McCurdy was a small-time criminal who
often bragged that his only arrest was for
being drunk in Kansas, where he had killed
a man in a drunken brawl.
After a variety of low-level crimes, McCurdy
turned to train robbery.
In 1911, he ambushed a train in Oklahoma.
He believed the train contained thousands
of dollars, but it turned out to be a passenger
train…
McCurdy got away with $46 and two jugs of
whiskey, the latter of which would perhaps
play a small role in his decision making process
that led to his demise.
As law men moved in on a somewhat drunk McCurdy,
who had taken refuge on a farm after the robbery,
he vowed that they would not take him alive,
boarding himself up in a hayshed.
McCurdy was right and he was killed in the
subsequent shoot-out.
His body was taken to a funeral parlor in
Oklahoma and no one came forward to claim
it.
The funeral parlor’s undertaker came up
with an ingenious idea- he embalmed the body
and charged customers a nickel apiece to see
“the bandit who wouldn’t give up”.
McCurdy’s body on display proved to be a
lucrative racket for the undertaker.
A while later, the undertaker was conned by
a traveling carnival owner, who claimed to
be the brother of McCurdy and wanted the body
so he could give it a respectful burial.
Reluctantly, the undertaker turned the body
over to the man, who immediately put it in
his traveling show.
Over the years, the body was passed off from
business to business and eventually ended
up at the Nu-Pike Museum and Park, where it
was stored and forgotten until that fateful
day in 1977 on the set of The Six Million
Dollar Man.
You might be wondering at this point why McCurdy
had a ticket and a penny in his mouth.
Starting all the way back with McCurdy’s
time at the undertaker’s establishment,
people would place coins in the mouth of McCurdy,
for who knows what reason.
It’s been speculated that this was simply
how they made payment for seeing the body;
or perhaps people were doing it for similar
reasons as to why we throw coins into fountains;
or maybe this was a throwback to the Ancient
Greek and Roman practice of putting coins
in people’s mouths so they could bribe Charon,
or similar such mouth/dead person traditions
practiced by many other cultures throughout
history.
Whatever the case, this practice appears to
have continued and at some point the last
to do this placed a penny in his mouth and
they or someone else also placed a ticket
stub to the museum where they were seeing
the body at the time, the Sonney Amusement’s
Museum of Crime in L.A.
It was lucky they included the ticket stub,
as this provided the necessary clue needed
to track down who the man was.
Once the mystery was unraveled, McCurdy’s
body was returned to Oklahoma and buried in
a cemetery.
The state medical examiner ordered two cubic
yards of concrete be poured over Elmer McCurdy’s
coffin, so his remains would never be bothered
again.
And so, after 66 years, the body of the luckless
man who made far more money dead than he ever
did alive, was finally put to rest.
Bonus Fact:
• After McCurdy fired on the officers and
they subsequently opened fire on the hayshed
McCurdy was in, he ceased to fire back.
Rather than go in and investigate themselves,
and possibly get shot if McCurdy was still
alive, they initially sent a young boy in
to investigate…
One can imagine the conversation: “You go…
No, you go…
Hey, let’s just send in
that kid.”